at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I ask you a personal
question no I must - netic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
[Music]
this episode of the Tim Farriss shows
brought to you by athletic greens I get
us all the time if I could only take one
supplement what would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
and I use it in a lot of different ways
I travel with it to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of these one
dose bags in other words if you buy
athletic greens as a first-time buyer
you now get for a limited time and extra
$79 in free product so check out the
details at athletic greens com forward
slash Tim again that's athletic greens
com forward slash Tim for your free
travel pack with any purchase
this episode is brought to you by
peloton I love peloton peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right to your
home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into your schedule
making it to the studio we're dealing
with some commute to the gym I have a
peloton bike in my master bedroom at
home and it is one of the first things
that I do in the morning I wake up
meditate for 20 minutes and then I knock
out a short 20 minute ride usually
high-intensity interval training or hit
then I take a shower and I'm in higher
gear for the rest of the day it's
beautifully convenient and has become
something that I actually look forward
to and I was skeptical in the beginning
I didn't think I would dig it and I
really do so you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride it live
with thousands of other peloton riders
from across the country on the
interactive leaderboard to keep you
motivated I tend to use a lot of the
classes on demand and have four to six
of them that I've bookmarked and use
over and over again there are up to 14
new classes every day with thousands of
classes on demand and there are a
variety of workouts to choose from 45
minute classes 20 minute burns hip hop
rock and roll low impact or
high-intensity pick the class structure
and style their works for you peloton
has an amazing roster of incredible
instructors in New York City they really
do have great instructors of every
possible personality and style and you
can find one that you love no matter
what you're in the mood for personally I
use Matt wolbers a lot but I use a bunch
of them I'm promiscuous and enjoy
classes from a lot of their instructors
with real time metrics you can track
your performance over time and continue
to beat your personal bests
I did not think the gamification would
work for me and they really hit the nail
on the head it does work at least for me
tremendously well to keep me pushing
consistently so discover this
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings us to do experience to your home
peloton is offering listeners of this
podcast a limited time offer go to one
peloton comm that's spelled o-n-e
PE l otan comm enter the code Tim
podcast all one word at checkout and get
$100 off accessories with your peloton
bike purchase get a great workout at
home anytime you want go to one peloton
calm and use the code Tim podcast to get
started hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct world
class performers people who are the best
or one of the best at what they do my
guest today is certainly that Ken Burns
you can find him on Twitter at Ken Burns
has been making documentary films for
more than 40 years since the Academy
award-nominated Brooklyn Bridge in 1981
ken has gone on to direct and produce
some of the most acclaimed historical
documentaries ever made including the
Civil War I'm gonna pause at this point
in the list because not everyone who's
listening to this has seen the Civil War
or realizes just how massively popular
it was now critics thought no one
watched Civil War why because it's more
than ten hours long and at the end of
the day it was broadcast on PBS on five
consecutive nights in 1990 and almost 40
million viewers more than actually 40
million viewers tuned into at least one
episode and viewership averaged more
than 14 million viewers each evening
making it the most watched program ever
to air on PBS now this is 40 million
plus people watching something that is
produced to be 10 plus hours long that's
this is not a 5 second video on YouTube
so let that sink in for a second but
back to the list so the Civil War
baseball jazz the Statue of Liberty Huey
Long Lewis and Clark Frank Lloyd Wright
Mark Twain unforgivable blackness
subtitle the rise and fall of Jack
Johnson for those you don't know Jack
Johnson was an incredible boxer the war
the national parks subtitle america's
best idea the Roosevelts Jackie Robinson
defying the Nazis subtitled the Sharps
war the Vietnam War and the Mayo Clinic
subtitle faith hope science Ken's films
have been honored with dozens of major
awards including 16 Emmy Awards two
Grammy Awards and two Oscar nominations
and in September of 2008 at the news and
documentary Emmy Awards ken was honored
by the Academy of Television Arts &
Sciences with a lifetime
an award his newest work is country
music I have it here right next to me it
explores the history of uniquely
American art form
country music from to deepen tangled
roots and ballads blues and hymns
performed in small settings to its
worldwide popularity learn how country
music evolved over the course of the
20th century as it eventually emerged to
become America's music country music
features never-before-seen footage and
photographs of course this is Ken's
trademark so to speak Plus interviews
with more than 80 country music artists
the eight part and 16-hour series is
directed and produced by none other than
Ken Burns written and produced by Dayton
Duncan and produced by Julie Dunphy it
debuts on PBS on Sunday September 15th
at 8:00 7:00 central again that's Sunday
September 15th at 8:00 7:00 central the
first four episodes will stream on line
on the PBS platforms including PBS org
and PBS apps timed to coincide with the
Sunday September 15th premiere and the
second four timed to the broadcast of
episode five on Sunday September 22nd so
each episodes will stream for a period
of three weeks the simple version of
that is on TV Sunday September 15th at 8
Eastern 7 central 8 Eastern 7 central
and if you do not have television if
you're a cord cutter you get a PBS
network or use one of the PBS apps PBS
passport members will be able to stream
the entire series for a period of six
months beginning Sunday September 15th
so all that said without further ado
please enjoy and my god that I enjoy it
this wide-ranging conversation with none
other than Ken Burns
ken welcome to the show thanks for
having me I am thrilled to be having
this conversation I've been a fan of
yours for effectively as long as I've
been consciously aware of what I'm
watching in front of me so I can't say
the first few years but sure and I
thought we might bounce around quite a
bit in this conversation and begin with
something that came up in the research I
did for this podcast episode and it
relates to mementos in your pocket do
you still carry mementos in your pocket
and whether it's past tense or current
tense present tense can you describe
what those are and why you carry them
sure I just I've just dug into my pocket
and amid some change I have four items
which I've had for many many years now
they know no one's been retired one of
them is a coin
Hamdani by an ex-marine who was the
headmaster at the Greenwood school and
tiny Putney Vermont the Greenwood school
is equally tiny and is a school for boys
with learning differences meaning they
suffer from dyslexia or ADHD or
executive function a host of things if
school addresses this problem head on
it's been around for about 40 years and
after Thanksgiving when the boys come
back ages 10 11 to 17 when they come
back from Thanksgiving vacation they are
all asked to memorize the ten
complicated sentences of Lincoln's
Gettysburg Address and then publicly
recite them a difficult task for any one
of us but if you have these learning
differences it can be a nightmare and
when the boys successfully complete that
they they are given the coin by the
headmaster in typical kind of military
fashion even though it's not a military
school and he's anything but
militaristic but I was asked once many
many years ago to be a judge I found
myself in tears
the effort of these boys to do it and
said somebody's got to make a film about
it
it obviously would be a cinema verite
film which is not my style but as the
150th anniversary of the Gettysburg
Address came up in 2013 I thought you
know what I gotta dive in and do it so
we embedded in the school with a sound
man and a cameraman and assistant and
recorded three hundred and some hours
and when the whole thing was over he and
we made the film and realized that the
kids had never in the then 35 years
history of the school been to Gettysburg
I rented two buses and took the whole
school there and put him up for a night
and gave them a tour of the battlefield
as the kind of coda to this film when it
was over he he pawned a medal in my
pocket so I have that Greenwood school
thing the oldest thing I have is what's
called a feeling heart it's a stainless
steel shape of a heart with a little
indentation in it so you can sort of
hold it in palm it it's not like a coin
it it has a little bit more dimension to
that and it's maybe you know much bigger
than the silver dollar and it was sent
to me by a woman in upstate New York an
artist who had fashioned this and she
had written after the Civil War series
was broadcast in September of 1990 and
sometime in the first few weeks after
that she had sent me a heart hi then got
another two hearts for my two oldest
daughters and recently got two more
hearts to give to my two young daughters
who are you know 14 and and eight and so
it just is always there I can feel it
and sometimes I find myself just you
know holding it in my hand I'm sure
doing exactly what she had intended the
heart to do another object I have was
given to me by a friend and it's a minie
ball now polished and free of all the
calcification that attends her the mini
ball is a bullet that would have been
used during the Civil War and it was
found on the on Gettysburg as well and
so I carry around a reminder
the time when we came closest to our
near national suicide when now it turns
out to the work of drew Gilpin Faust the
former president of Harvard's
extraordinary scholarship that instead
of the six hundred or six hundred and
twenty thousand that was generally
accepted as a death toll in the Civil
War it looks like it's more like seven
hundred and fifty thousand three
quarters of a million well more than two
percent of the population an
extraordinary death toll you know in the
poem Casey at the bat says in this
favored land and then the fourth and
final object that I've carried around
for years and years as a button off a
jacket of a friend of mine father his
son gave it to me so the friend of Mines
grandfather as well war on an army
uniform and he had landed at d-day at
Normandy and so I've just kind of kept
these reminders in my pocket and they're
comforting I do have one object that I
can't fit in my pocket but I have next
to me at my desk at home in New
Hampshire and it's leg irons that I
purchased at auction heavy weighty
horrible things they are a human
invention whose only purpose is to keep
other human beings in bondage which is a
legacy of a very difficult part of our
history and reckoning we still not have
fully completed and it turns out that
though I don't necessarily go looking
for it in my projects that that that
question is always lingering in in in
our American story and whether it's
country music it's there whether it's in
the national parks it's there in
unlikely places that's there in likely
places like a biography of Jackie
Robinson or Jack Johnson or jazz but it
seems to this question of the fact that
we know we were born under the sign that
all men are created equal but the guy
who wrote that second sentence of the
Declaration our Creed
more than 200 even beings when he wrote
and didn't see the contradiction or the
hypocrisy and more important didn't see
fit in this lifetime to free anyone of
those human beings who had any alienable
rights and so you know if you're going
to do a deeper dive and just mere
regurgitation of conventional wisdom
then you have to deal with this
ever-present subject of race and so I
wish I could tell you that it could
carry around those leg irons but they
don't fit in the pocket and they have a
weight and a disturbing heaviness to
them that that is nevertheless very
close to me when I'm at home can you
have a a remarkable memory and you also
must receive be offered to be exposed to
thousands of different objects that you
could keep what you said as reminders
earlier are there particular reasons why
you chose of all the other options let's
start with the objects in your pocket
what is what purpose do those serve for
you well you know you're asking a
question which requires an answer from
the head and I'm not sure the head made
the decision to keep them I think the
heart did and the heart doesn't
necessarily have a rational or easily
articulated response to the question
which is a good one and an obvious one
and I wish I could be truthful and and
honest I mean I do get lots of stuff
objects and mainly these are things that
are close to me I mean I had never
thought when I received this healing
heart that I would put it in my pocket
but I did instinctively and it's never
left I mean I can't tell how many times
I'd emptied it to go through TSA
screenings you know it it's really there
and there's a kind of commitment and
loyalty to it that that I can't explain
and the bullet was given to me by a
friend and he I adore him he is one of
my closest friends
he's a he's a big bear of a loving man
and I just sort of felt the you know
there's something so contradictory about
a bullet being anything but a bad thing
and yet it represents all of the
totality of the Civil War the woman who
had sent this feeling Hart wrote in her
letter that she saw the series that we
made on the Civil War as an American
Baja gávea you know this you know store
yeah and you just kind of went whoa and
I I don't think I was
it was the splattery of that that stuck
it in my pocket it was something of it
and it may have been the struggles that
it took me to go through the growth that
I'd undergone obviously these kids at
the Greenwood school had moved me to my
core and I just presumed that some other
filmmaker better equipped to do a cinema
verite film would do it but found myself
having to do it and found myself with a
crew that was really excited and and was
able to get a lot of fly-on-the-wall
stuff and it meant a lot to me and the
button is the button is the button you
know the greatest invasion in human
history took place on June 6 1944 on the
northwest coast of France that ended
what you know if Hitler had and ended
began to end in 12 years what the Adolf
Hitler had intended to be a
thousand-year Reich well let's talk
about I would like to talk about the
heart and maybe that's almost a
contradiction in terms but I have been
very hyper analytical my whole life and
I think if Nick elected to pay attention
to signals from the body and I've been
trying to cultivate this over the last
few years in particular and a woman I'm
named Diana Chapman and Jim Detmer
introduced me to this concept of the
whole the whole body or the full body
yes and I've read that at least in
response to questions like when you
start one of these big movies what's the
first
that you talk about looking for the big
wholehearted yes that isn't coming from
your head but your are kind of like
falling in love right and so what I've
been trying to do is pay attention to
the sensations whether it's heart
centered or gut centered to assess
whether something is a full yes for me
what what does a full wholeheartedness
feel like yeah and and could you give us
an example of a project where that was a
clear signal sure I think the best
example is the one sort of right in
front of us which is country music I had
had country music as an intellectual
didactic expository idea if that's what
it was on a list that I've recently
found from the 1990s and from another
list from the Ott's meaning that I was
thinking about right and there might be
50 different things you you know the
lottery where they've got all these
ping-pong balls bouncing around and then
one drop us down it imagine these are
all just completely arbitrary head
things I just an idea oh we should do
this we should think about that what
about this and so you just want to write
them down so you don't forget them and
whatever but nothing happens and nothing
did happen and I had forgotten that they
were even there but I remember visiting
a friend of mine in Dallas Texas who had
been raising money for us and wonderful
dear friend and I came down for
breakfast one day we done event I was
staying at this house and I guess we
were the first people up and he said you
ever thought about country music and
when he said it it was like this huge
whole body explosion and I looked at him
and was just I could feel it in my chest
and I could feel it in my gut and so it
wasn't I started to answer yes mm-hmm
and then I realized that that yes was so
feeble and so partial because it had to
do was sort of trying to be oh yeah well
it's on a list you know like that that I
realized that the my like physical and
more importantly my emotional reaction
to that had completely obliterated what
little blip it was as a kind of mental
construct that had worked its way in the
nineties and later the arts onto a sheet
of paper with ten twenty thirty other
subjects some of which I've done some of
which I haven't done some of which I'll
get to some of which I will never get to
and so this was something else and so as
I I kind of felt like I got down on one
knee I didn't physically and proposed to
country music at that there was a big
yes now the the biggest thing I knew is
that this project would have to go
through one of my partners who I knew
knew more about country music and more
importantly he and I had been thinking
about another big project and we're just
throwing around some ideas and doing a
little research could we possibly pull
this off and we were not in quicksand
but we were you know our back rear right
tire is stuck and I went back to New
Hampshire and I went to him and I said
what about look we don't need to abandon
this other thing but what about country
music
and it's like he looked at me like he
just and the two of us I mean that and
from that moment I mean I do remember
what the other project was but it you
know we hadn't shot anything we hadn't
written anything there have been no
budget raise four it was just purely
conceptual stuff it was dropped in favor
of the next eight and a half years of
work and it was you know you say total
this is wholeheartedness that's what it
is it has to be the integration so that
you you physically commit to it you you
mentally commit to it but you
emotionally commit to it and that yes is
very similar to the chemistry we feel
with others when we fall in love either
romantically or as friends and as as all
the films have been it's just been a
wholehearted yes because you realize
that the story is fire or the stories
are firing on all cylinders that they're
complex they represent challenge and
opportunity and difficulty you know I
once was with a group of students
recently and I told them that every film
that I'd done was at least a million
problems but I didn't think but I didn't
think that the word problem was
necessarily pejorative
that it represented friction that needed
to be overcome
it was the necessary friction of the
creative process of the making progress
you know you just that wall won't hold
itself up so builder you need to have
scaffolding in falsework
that once you've reached a certain stage
can be disassembled so this is what we
had to do and how do you take you're not
going to be the Encyclopedia you're not
going to be the reading of the telephone
book how do you take something as
monstrously big as the Civil War
baseball or jazz or the national parks
or World War two or the Roosevelt's or
Vietnam or now country music and say
what do we tell where do we start how do
we go back and pick up its ancestors
where do we end how do we tell this
story just really practical things that
have to do with the craft and the art of
filmmaking and larger big question
things and all of that represents in the
case of the theories maybe millions of
individual problems in quotes but if you
look at them as as is just whatever a
runner takes to overcome that brain that
screaming stop as you're running a
marathon then you understand what we're
engaged in because people always come up
and say wow you just spent ten and a
half years on Vietnam eight and a half
years on country music how do you do
that I said I'm sad I don't want to
leave it you know it's not like the fact
I'm talking to you is one of the
palliative kind of aspects of this the
promotional permit is the area of
permitted to leave the project because
all of a sudden you've been attending to
the stories we lift up and you begin to
share it with other people and they
begin to synthesize some ideas and you
know they're saying oh you intended this
and you say no we didn't we just wanted
to tell the story but now that you're
saying this we realized the way in which
this historical moment say resonates in
the present Harry Truman once said the
only
that's really new is the history you
don't know people are so fond of saying
history repeats itself it does not Mark
Twain is supposed to say that history is
supposed to have said that history
doesn't repeat itself but it rhymes and
if he did say that he is so on the mark
because I believe that human nature
doesn't change Ecclesiastes put it this
way you know there's nothing new Under
the Sun that's the Old Testament and
that may be the best what has been will
be again what has been done will be done
again there's nothing new Under the Sun
and so I think that that suggests that
human nature doesn't change and that it
super imposes itself over the seemingly
random chaos of events and we begin to
perceive patterns and echoes and feeds
rhymes Twain would say and I love that
we attend to the storytelling part of it
I happen to work in American history the
way somebody painter works in oil as
opposed to watercolor unfortunately the
word history is mostly made up with the
word story plus hi you know you don't
have to get into the binary his story or
her story it's just story plus hi which
is a wonderful greeting and you know we
finish it and then we look up and go my
god it is resonating with the present
and every single film I've done like you
will look at country music and you will
cannot believe that we were editorially
complete before the me2 movement started
you will go oh no oh no they were aware
of the Miche movement and they and they
they just worked it in or I used to
start my stump speech for the Vietnam
War series that came out in 2017 so
imagine where we'd been for the first
nine months of 2017 and for the
preceding election year and I said what
if I told you that I had been working
for ten and a half years about mass
demonstrations taking place all across
the country against the current
administration about a white house in
disarray obsessed with leaks about a
president certain the press was making
up stories about him lying about
asymmetrical wharf
that confounded the Mighty Mite of the
US military about huge big document
drops of stolen classified material into
the products fear that he stabilized the
political equation and accusations that
a political party reached out to a
foreign power during the time of a
national election to influence that
election you would say had been working
on the last year and a half but all of
these things were true of the Vietnam
War when I started in December of 2006
and we're also true when we finished
lock the picture no more work on it in
in December of 2015 a month before the
Iowa caucuses out of which Donald Trump
was not supposed to emerge as a
candidate and that's I could take any
film any film and do that that I've
worked on and it's nothing that we're
prepared for it's only an after-the-fact
kind of collection of accounting that
bittersweet period when you get a chance
to you know finish the film you don't
want to leave it and so you're obligated
because of the shoe leather necessary to
promote public broadcasting films you do
in 40 cities and you begin to construct
something that talks about how you
related to it but it's true of
everything every some cluding the civil
war you know every film I've made it
just resonates in the present and
suggest the 20ms absolutely correct
yeah it is a that's one hell of a rhyme
and I have a question about motivation
you mentioned eight and a half years ten
plus years some people have signs in
their office these motivational quotes
of various types effectively some
version of go get'em tiger you can do it
et cetera I have read that you have a
neon sign in your editing room yeah what
does it read and how did you choose this
particular sign well you know filmmakers
are notorious for once something works
you don't touch it right you say I leave
that alone it's work
right and that may be great in Hollywood
but if you find out new and
contradictory facts you're kind of
obligated to to do it and we never have
a set research period followed by a set
writing period followed by a script
that's now retched in stone that informs
the shooting and the editing we never
stop researching so we're always finding
out stuff and we never stop writing so
we're always corrigible and willing to
be flexible in what we do and we're
often filming interviewing before we've
even written a word of a script so that
every time you see a talking head in our
film it's a happy accident it's not that
I've gone to you and it said hey you
know mr. Ferris could you please get me
from paragraph 2 two paragraphs tree and
episode four thank you thank you you
know can you say that again but do it
with a little bit more economy yeah that
was it but now could you end the way you
did the first we've never done that we
just go and have an interview and if it
doesn't work it's our fault if it works
it's their greatness right and so we
have this complex process that I think
serves us very well in in the pursuit of
a complicated story so what's the neon
sign it says it's complicated and it's
the license to say even if it's perfect
even if it's working let's open it up
and add in that that complicated
conflicting contradictory fact and sure
it might destabilize it but let's let's
do it anyway and so it just says in
cursive lowercase it's complicated and
in the Antonine and it's something we've
said to each other for a long time it's
it's sometimes like a scarf or a muffler
warm gloves on a cold day it just arms
you against the the scariness of going
out into that unknown region and other
times it's just like yeah this is what
we do and I wanted it I finally
immortalized that by putting it in neon
so that we could all remember that this
is what we celebrate that's that
remember making films years ago on the
Statue of Liberty I interview
the now past statesman Saul Lin oh it's
wonderful interview and he was quoting
judge learn at hand could there ever be
a better name for a jurist than learn at
hand and apparently learn at hand said
liberty is never being too sure you're
right and I'm sure he meant it in a
rather narrow political perhaps
jurisprudence sense but I took it in a
broad spiritual sense you know that the
opposite of faith is not heresy it's
it's not doubt it's it's just conviction
right so faith requires doubt it doesn't
require it doesn't require certainty and
and what we've tried to do is instill in
ourselves which is the hardest thing to
do it seems easier to try to instill it
in others this idea that that we're not
done we got to open this up again and
we've learned contradictory stuff and
we're you know for a while our Vietnam
script its footnotes were longer than
the script itself like we would say poor
regiments of Vietcong for measurements
of NVA went down the Ho Chi Minh Trail
that month and we'd have an asterisk or
you know footnote 117 and footnote 117
would say you know this scholar says
this this scholar says that this scholar
says that because it's in these two
places were going with four but later on
we found out after we locked a film that
yet another scholar had said three and
we were beginning to feel a little bit
more comfortable with that and would
rather err on the conservative side and
so we changed we found where the
narrator had said the word three and we
cannibalized it and moved it over
sometimes you call it a Franken byte and
we put the three and instead of the four
so that we could just exhale a little
bit no one would ever in a million years
not even a scholar take us to task for
it but that was not acceptable
for us so we'd rather and if we haven't
been able to find that that that tree we
would have asked a narrator back-end
Peter Coyote back in and and record it
I'd like to talk about the Civil War and
maybe we could start with a question
about civil wars do you have any idea
how many people have seen have watched
the Civil War do have any estimates on
no idea I know we reached about 40
million people who watched some or all
of it the first time is broadcast about
this time 29 years ago in September of
1990 and I know that in subsequent
broadcast that's done very well it's you
know in works itself into schools many
many other people look at it regularly
so I assume it might be you know a
couple multiples of that original forty
million as it's gone out those are
astronomical numbers I mean there's huge
huge numbers and yet yeah 20 plus years
ago television critics at least some
thought nobody would watch the Civil War
for many reasons including that you know
this new musical cop Rock was going to
blow you out of the water that didn't
end up being case and what what I wonder
especially given the ridge we were just
talking about faith conviction and so on
have have you have you as someone who
comes across say in an interview like
this as completely confident and and
clear in focus have you ever felt lost
or had self-doubt are there any stories
that you can paint just to provide a
maybe a fleshed out human picture of you
could could you die and time or any
difficult time that you've gone through
well I am a very very anxious person and
I now don't have too much time for
anxiety because people that I love are
anxious now too
and I've got to give my attention to
them so the early days the first film on
the Brooklyn Bridge through the Civil
War were
agonizing every morning up at 4:00 a.m.
I remember I asked Shelby Foote about
grants and he said grant meaning us
grant had what they call four o'clock in
the morning courage that meant that you
could wake him up at four o'clock in the
morning and tell him the enemy had
turned his left front can he be as cool
as a cucumber I remember thinking oh my
god I wish I had four o'clock in the
morning courage and I think I've
developed it now and I've learned how to
harness it and turn it around but it was
debilitating crushing anxiety about
whether this would work you know I I was
told while I was making the Civil War
that yes sure these first six films on
the Brooklyn Bridge and the shakers and
Huey Long in the Statue of Liberty and
Congress and Thomas Hart Benton an hour
and a half an hour in length people will
watch steel photographs of that long but
they're not going to look for the 5-1
hours that initially we proposed the
Civil War to be and it ended up being
nearly twelve hours in length and that
that was terrifying to be told that over
and over again and I remember I knew the
film was good when it was done but I
remember arriving in Los Angeles for the
Television Critics Association meeting
and several of the critics would say Ken
it's terrific but you know nobody's
going to watch it because of this cop
rocks show by Steven Bochco
but more because we were in an age when
people were addicted to MTV cutting and
that two and a half minutes was the
length of the American attention span
and I remember thinking wow that's too
bad you know it was let it didn't
produce anxiety the where the actual
making of the film did and I'm so
grateful for those loved ones and
colleagues and sometimes they were both
who shored me up and pretended that I
was okay or you know covered for me if
it was just to too much really really
important people still in my life to
this day but I remember thinking that I
thought that all real meaning accrued in
duration that the work were proudest of
that your Protestant I would presume
that the relationships you care the most
about
have benefited from our sustained
attention and that it's okay to have
both that we do need the fast-paced fast
cutting to an admitted MTV music video
just as today as people who were telling
me during the aughts that no one would
watch the the national parks or the
world war two because of youtube which
you know meant that kitten with a ball
of yarn well these could coexist that
that's a that the stuff we cared about
that all meaning accrued and duration
was an important thing and what was true
is the Civil War bored out I mean then
as soon as we were working on baseball
they said she's eighteen and a half
hours not not even eleven hours and
forty minutes
there's Civil War but eighteen and a
half hours nobody's gonna watch that and
there was a strike and and everybody did
and jazz oh man nobody's going to watch
you know 18 hours of black people right
I just said I think so or for the
National Parks that's not a travelogue
that's not a you know which Lodge or
into you should have your family's at
and so I just started trusting at some
point along the way and I got I got a I
it's funny that you asked this because
I've just been dealing it recently with
a loved one I developed in the early to
mid 90s a sort of sense of three things
I call them my one of my daughter's
calls them the three truths I'm not
willing to elevate them to that I just
called the three things that I try to do
as I help others friends and and loved
ones with anxiety of this debilitating
kind that this will pass you know all
things are transitory get help from
others and be kind to yourself and if I
had to do a neon sign another neon sign
I think I'd do the three things and I've
learned to internalize them in in large
measure because like that alcoholic or
drug addict who becomes the most
effective counselor somebody who's been
through the ringer of it is I think a
much better is
much more authentic spokesperson man
this goes back to country this is at the
heart of it is the sincerity or the
authenticity that is at the heart of
these relatively simple songs that are
as the songwriter Harlan Howard said
three chords and the truth
so it's acknowledging that there's a
simplicity to it doesn't have
sophistication or the complication of
classical music or some forms of jazz
but that back-end the truth it means
it's dealing with universal human things
and I find the universality of those
three things similar to the
effectiveness of a good country song
charley pride says in the introduction
that I think there's a country song for
every mood you're in it might make you
cry but you'll feel better for crying
sister so if you hear Hank Witt here
Hank Williams say hear that Lonesome
whippoorwill he sounds too blue to fly
the midnight train is whining oh I'm so
lonesome I could cry you know I you know
if you've got music which went in
Marsalis is in this film and country
music not just jazz is the art of the
invisible the only art form that's
invisible is music and you add to it
poetry which is the distillation of
language our form of communication then
your mainlining a completely benign form
of heroin emotional heroin right into
your bloodstream and it gets there
really quick and it's it's its effects
are only positive this is the hank
williams who also wrote i've got a hot
rod ford in a $2 bill and I know a place
right over the hill you know and goes on
to talk about the joy of young love or
the possibility of new love in that just
as he speaks you know the silence of a
falling star lights up a purple sky and
as I wonder where you are I'm so
lonesome I can cry you know there's just
there's no one within the sound of my
voice that has not experienced that I
moved to Austin Texas a few years ago
and spent a lot of time on Willie Nelson
Boulevard I saw him perv or saw him
perform recently at Austin City Limits
and my I think my memory serves me right
that he
he was part of the pilot for that series
in 1972 is it's it's and it was just
spectacular just absolutely spectacular
so I'm looking forward to digging into
country music I did have a follow-up
question on the three truths as your
daughter calls them the third in
particular be kind to yourself could
yeah that's hard yeah it's a hardest for
me - could you describe what that looks
like for you are there any practices or
things that you now say to yourself yeah
III can I can talk myself down from the
first thing I'm smart enough to surround
myself with people that are willing to
put up with doing what the second thing
into but I am a complete failure on that
last thing - I
I can pay lip service to it only because
I know it's true and it's therefore not
phony it isn't lip service it is the
truth but I think this is the hardest
thing for all of us is how to be kind to
ourselves how do we how do we not murder
this moment how do we how do we prepare
ourselves for the next moment whatever
it is and to try to liberate ourselves
from the prison of the contemplation of
the past which may promote depression
not to not to deny the chemical organs
of that nor anxiety which is an
anticipation in the future Thomas
Jefferson had a wonderful thing how much
pain has caused us the evils which have
never happened and I didn't really
surprise me that Tom who was really good
at ignoring some fundamental things
right in front of him like the fact that
he lived in a plantation and his
comfortable life was due entirely to
people that he owned and did not pay
could realize too that the basic
elements of the human heart
often have to do with worry what that is
is a great late 18th century or maybe he
wrote it in the early 19th century
commentary about work how much pain has
caused the evils which have never
happened Thomas Jefferson was was also a
fan of Seneca the younger and whether
the philosophical school of stoicism as
was George Washington who had a play
about Cato performed at Valley Forge to
bolster the morale of the troops are
there any do you gravitate to any
particular philosophies or philosophical
writings if not that you have to but I
met me you're very well-read clearly
well you know I love what Jeffery Ward
who's my longtime writing collaborator
along with Dayton Duncan jeff has been
writing a little bit longer and he wrote
the Roosevelts and he was quoting
Franklin Roosevelt when I asked it what
his philosophy was he said he was a
Christian and an American and left it at
that and you know at the end of the day
I'll hide behind FDR's skirts you know I
am I think Christian I'm not a
practicing Christian but I'd like to
believe that I'm a believing Christian
and that I'm an American and that
basically says that I do not need to hew
to any one political philosophy because
there's always the possibility and in
fact it isn't a possibility there's
always the certainty that the opposite
of what I might believe in might also be
true and that requires the nimbleness of
human that requires a human dexterity
that the binary aspects of politics and
don't subscribe to and that's why I
think FDR said is exactly right and I
have friends as close colleagues as
possible who I guess would call them
selves atheists and others who
have other faiths in addition to
Christianity but this is what I yeah I
am what I am I think Popeye said and I
like I like both you know I like I like
that American part you know it's for all
the things that we've screwed up for all
of the things we've gotten so wrong
I do believe as Lincoln said and his
message to Congress what we'd call the
State of the Union in December of 1862
that we were the last best hope of urge
that this myth of exceptionalism poisons
us and pollutes us and allows us to
incubate isolated as we are by these two
magnificent oceans that have protected
us as well permits us to incubate so
many horrible tendencies an addiction to
money and guns and suspicions of the
other it you know I I have spent my
entire professional life living in a
kind of space I like to think about it
will sound absurd you as I explained it
between the two letter lowercase plural
pronoun us and it's capitalized version
the u.s. that is to say all of the
intimacy and warmth of us along with we
and our and all of the Brett's the
majesty the complexity the contradiction
even the controversy of the United
States and what I've learned over 40
plus years of practicing in my
professional life telling stories in
American history about us and the u.s.
is that there's only us there's no them
you know country music has been since
the very beginning and alloy a mixture
of things stronger because it has
constituent elements that make it
stronger and that at any time in our
history when we suggest that pulling out
one aspect of it will make it pure
American you have a priori weakened the
ally and made it the riddle and more
breakable and I like our supplements
I like our madness I like our mongrel
mess which is of course abhorrent to
various currents that are boiling and
swirling in the United States this is
what makes us stronger the banjo one of
the key instruments of country music is
from Africa ap Carter of the Carter
Family the original Carter Family
Bill Monroe the founder of bluegrass the
four mentioned Hank Williams and Johnny
Cash people who deserve to be on the
Mount Rushmore of early country music
all had an african-american tutor that
took their chops from here to way up
here to qualify them for consideration
in that pantheon on that Mount Rushmore
and Jimmie Rodgers the first superstar
at the same times as a Carter family
grew up sisters with the blues sung by
the black train crews that he worked
with in Southern Mississippi so while he
didn't have one mentor the way Hank
Williams did Rufus T taught Payne about
whom he said everything I learned about
music I got from Rufus that's that's not
bad for arguably the most important
country singer-songwriter it just tells
you that whatever superficial thing
you've got about country music in your
head whatever conventional wisdom that
you think your now are going to enjoy it
ain't true that it's always been a
mixture and it's always been mostly
working class business story of women
really strong women from the very very
beginning it's the story of people
coming out of poverty black and white
and changing the dynamics of their lives
and if they didn't bring other people
out they gave them at least the tools to
dream how to do that it's about
geographical dislocation and
psychological dislocation and at the end
of the day this extraordinary marriage
of this invisible artform combined with
the poetry of the words and the for us
has filmmaker startling emotion we did
not ever expect to find in the story of
country music
like to ask a question about the making
of Ken Burns because you said I am when
I am which is true you are what you are
I can't deny that but I mic my
girlfriend said to be recently over
dinner she was she was she was quoting
someone else but she said that every
every child is born into a different
family in the sense that if you have two
or three siblings as people change over
time you're born into a different family
and likewise I would imagine that there
are certain aspects of Kenneth's that
have remained the same for a long time
but you made choices that have shaped
who you are today and I wanted to ask
about one in particular and this is
Hampshire College could ya could you
talk about Hampshire describe Hampshire
College and how you ended up there
because I actually do not know okay so I
I am the son of an anthropologist and a
mother who had an advanced degree in
biology but couldn't really use it she
raised two sons until she died of cancer
in 1965 which is the dominant event of
my life yeah shortly afterwards I
watched my father cry at a movie and
decided I wanted to be a filmmaker I had
seen the safe-haven that it had provided
for him a man who I had never seen cry
not through my mother's illness not on
her death not at us you know a point
pointed out to me by phones which I knew
who meant that was there was an implicit
criticism and I saw my dad cry at a
movie called odd man out anyway I was
going to be a Hollywood director
so Flash board I am in my senior year of
high school in Ann Arbor Michigan and my
best friend subscribes to a magazine
apparently that I had never heard of
called Newsweek our families subscribed
to Time magazine I didn't know there was
anything else but Time magazine for a
news weekly which I devoured by that
time covered a cover and here was the
description of a tiny experimental
college that had just opened in the last
few weeks this is October of 1970 it had
opened in September of 1970 which was
four
lack of a better word a graduate school
experience at an undergraduate level
that is to say you were trusted to
either know what you wanted to do or to
find out what you wanted to do and you
proceeded in much the same fashion you
would in graduate school with a D
emphasis on class work and more emphasis
on independent study and the assembling
of your own examinations your own
proposals and the assembling of a
faculty small faculty group of two or
three who would judge it along the way
and finally pass on it pass or fail
I like falling in love with country
music it just lit me up and I said I
want to go there he said I'm applying
and I was supposed to go to the
University of Michigan where I could get
in for free or nominal stuff because my
dad taught there I Hampshire was the
most expensive College on earth room
board and tuition in the fall of 71 the
class to which I hope to enter in was
four thousand seven hundred and thirty
dollars thirty dollars more than Harvard
University and I basically moved all my
chips I quit school early I had advanced
placement courses that permitted me to
interpret the Michigan laws that said I
needed oh X number of credits not four
years of high school or three years of
high school and that I had that and that
I was leaving after Christmas and the
guidance counselor said you were making
a big mistake and I worked in a record
store part-time I now went full-time to
that saved up money my grandmother gave
me a thousand dollars I had inherited a
thousand dollars I pushed all my chips
into year one fully intending to come
back to Michigan just having you know
blown it all on that you know experiment
I so fell in love with Hampshire I am so
a poster boy for it that I couldn't not
do it so I quit I took a leave from
Hampshire my second year and worked
literally as an indentured servant to a
dear friend still who ran the bookstore
at the college and got enough money to
pay for the next two years of Hampshire
and though it took four years I spent
only three years actually matriculating
there and ended up with a Bachelor of
Arts in film study
and design and I left there with this
sort of naive and perhaps arrogant
assumption that I could start my own
film company rather than do what
everyone else was supposed to do which
is go to New York or LA or whatever big
city and apprentice at a film company
and work your way up so I started with
two other Hampshire grads Florentine
films in 1976 a year after I graduated
though we'd been talking and thinking
about it for a long time and that's been
my only employer meaning I've got the
worst boss ever which is me two quick
questions Thank You ham Hampshire with
central central we had two teachers film
and photography teachers mostly still
photographers social documentary still
photographers Elaine mains and Jerome
Leland they became mentors in the best
sense of the word almost in a Medieval
Renaissance sense of a real master
student relationship and my relationship
with Jerry Liebling was complete through
to the end of his life he died in 2011 I
still worship Him and all that he gave
me I wish he did not exist you would not
be having this conversation I said that
you know once Dizzy Gillespie said of
Louis Armstrong know him know me know
Gerry Liebling know me . . what are some
of the things that stuck with you from
Jerry or were imprinted upon you that
had such a tremendous impact or was it
as care for you how would you describe
what was him he was a he was a
curmudgeonly kind of tough guy I
remember I was a precocious film student
all through high school not having any
formal courses to take but studying and
reading and I knew stuff and I had a
sentence which I think I can still do
from Andrew Sarris one of the great
critics and proponents of the French
auteur theory that the director is the
author of the film and he was talking
about Nicholas ray who made rebel
without a cause but he also made a film
called Johnny Guitar
whose screenwriter was Philip Yordan who
was eventually
blacklisted during those terrible
Hollywood days in the 50s and so there
was a sentence that I had looked at and
the perplexed and you'll understand
exactly why perplexed teenager where it
said Jordan set out to attack
McCarthyism but Ray was too delirious to
pay any heed as freudian feminism and
Marxist masochism prevailed over Pierre
and Ellen transcended polemics and to me
that was my Holy Grail right so I
finally got up a nerve second semester
of Hampshire to i-i've been in a lane
maze his his colleagues and younger
colleagues and somebody he had imported
to Hampshire the year I came the second
year he'd come the first year and I
showed this sentence I went into his
office and I suddenly like just said
blurted it out I was showing off right
now not only had I memorized it but I
think I knew what it meant I'd like to
have this discussion with him and when I
finished the seven she looked at me and
he got from his desk and he walked
around the desk and he took me by the
elbow which he always did to everybody
both in affectionate ways but this was
clearly not an affectionate way he sort
of lifted me out of my chair
moved me to the door opened the door and
pushed me out into the hallway and shut
the door
and I sat out there contemplating
suicide because Gerry was known for this
to being a terrifying person I thought
here all going out disarmed him with
this wonderful sentence which I was
going to attempt to deconstruct and
everything would be great and my career
such as it is and I rarely used the word
career after that would be launched and
he had reminded me this was just absurd
gobbledygook that Hollywood called
itself the industry which ought to be
warning enough and we were interested in
something else he was a great great
still photographer I urge you to google
him Liebling Lieb l ing extraordinary
photographs which he put up in our in
our classes along with our
and our films and they're stunning he
was about his he wanted us to know
history he wanted us to know ethics he
wanted us to be humanists he understood
there was a there was an essential
reciprocity that took place stuff didn't
occur stuff wasn't imparted just during
classes often he'd say my car's broken
down can you drive into northampton the
next town over and i'll pick up the
laundry i said sure and along the way
you'd get look at the way that angle of
that light hit she see the the way that
woman brushed her arm there and it
wasn't kind of say this is a good thing
or a bad thing he was just saying notice
as his daughters say he would always say
go see do be go get out into the world
see look around you do make something
you know relate you have an exchange of
something be take it in go see do be and
that to me along with hampshire is sort
of secret sauce of how they organized it
was it i do not recognize the person who
went into Hampshire in September of 1971
and the person who left in May or June
of 75 I just completely rearranged my
molecules and I have always had this
extraordinary devotion and affection for
it
and when I lost Jerry when we lost Gary
his family obviously his teaching had
reached so many people that we all still
gather and collect to talk about him
what he and Elaine had had given us over
those years and how transformative that
exposure to their generosity
whether it was artistic or human it
really doesn't matter and I loved the
fact that in retrospect those lines were
blurred you know some of the best times
I've ever had in my life were at his
house you know where we could we just go
and listen yes I really looked back also
on my own history and the mentors who
had the largest impact certainly had no
clear boundary between sort of work yeah
work hours and off hours and and that's
the same now true
me that is to say I I don't distinguish
I mean I understand that the world sort
of Sunday night gets a little bit
unhappy and that I know Friday afternoon
is some saying that's supposed to be
good I don't have that I don't have that
the cliche is if you love your work you
don't work a day in your life
and you know it is a cliche I'm still
supplying one at that but it's it's
pretty true the people I love are the
people I work with I work with my
daughter she's one of my producers she
teaches me stuff as my son-in-law all
the time and people I mean my
cinematographer we barely talked to one
another we have been working together
for 46 years I mean he was at Hampshire
he was at Hampshire and now we just we
go into situations and it's just sort of
it's almost like telepathy where we just
through him you know what look a little
gesture or whatever and all of it if you
were talking to buddy Squires who is
this extraordinary cinematographer about
Garrity you'd be hearing different sorts
of thing
but the meaning would be exactly what
I've been parted about Gerry Leland
Jerome Liebling how did your how did
your father respond if at all to your
decision to put all of your chips push
all of your chips onto the table for
this one thing particularly given that
you only had funds for one year
well the conversation arc are know I
think a lot of it had to do with some
stuff that was there that that befell
him he was not as mentally sound as he
should be I came across a few years ago
a letter from my mother to his mother
her mother-in-law in which she's saying
I'm dying
mm what am I going to do with my little
boys he can't he can't possibly take
care of them and we muddled through we
did okay and I think when I decided this
he knew in some respects that I needed
to get out of Dodge
I couldn't be at the scene of the crime
that is the death the place where my
mother had died and I think because he
wasn't financially involved he had no
resources he was in a kind of publisher
parish situation with University of
Michigan which eventually ended up with
the perishing he was in no position to
help so it was really I was going to do
this and I think he was happy for me
that I had found the clutch necessary to
put myself in gear because he's still
the most brilliant man I've ever met
like a Maserati my younger brother
district' described demands without a
clutch oh you can rev the engine in the
driveway but you can't go anywhere and
that was my dad was the the presenting
symptom of the missing clutch depression
or something that resembled depression
and what if you don't mind me asking I
believe so no no I believe I think we
would all generally agree that it was
probably bipolar but no significant
attempt was made at a diagnosis he was
eventually ended up at a sort of
tertiary level University in Western
Michigan and got somebody who was
supposed to help him who didn't really
and so we never really he was never
really treated for that but it it was
you know it was a sad sad like time
however he's the smartest person I've
ever met he was an amateur still
photographer and a professional
anthropologist and my very first memory
the first little film strip that runs
through my head is him just a couple
seconds of him building a darkroom in
the basement of our tract house in
Newark Delaware where he was the only
anthropologist in the state of Delaware
and then the next clip is of me being
held in his very strong left arm as he
manipulated the tongs in that finished
darkroom one of the few things he
finished in that eerie red light with
those ghastly smells of the chemicals as
I watched the miracle
a picture come out of a blank page and
if you think about what I do
there is an answer apology to it and it
is rooted in the DNA my DNA of my work
is a still photograph
even if I've got all the footage in the
world I will still often default for
real need to communicating with a single
still image and that's my dad as much as
it is your own labeling and Alain Vaes
it's my dad with the kind of
anthropology the story of us and so a
lot of you know strengths and I hope
goodness comes came from my mother who I
had a very short time with on this earth
I mean I
we just passed this past April 60 55
years without a mother which I have to
tell you to them is way too long to be
without a mother but at the same time
she is present every single day of my
life and the way my father isn't and yet
I actually have to pay him the honor of
having created not only me but my
brother and my mother too and my brother
Rick is much more understanding of this
and we just had an interesting
conversation together at the Telluride
Film Festival which was supposed to be
talking about us as filmmakers and we
immediately went to this dynamic and he
spoke about him as healing the physical
love of my mother and me always kind of
pushing away and going out and doing
things and having projects and so the
thing that I'm lacking is that sense of
ultimate security which he actually has
if not the ability to execute in quite
the same way that I am and so it's just
one of the most amazing conversations
I've ever had in my life with the gift
of my brother speaking truth to a
situation that informs every film I made
I mean my I was going through a crisis
and my father and well my late
father-in-law said to me
I said I seem to be keeping my mother
alive because I couldn't be
present on the day she died April 28 he
was always is always approaching and
then always disappearing but I was never
aware of that day and he said I bet you
blew out your candles as a young boy
wishing she'd come back i said i did it
my last birthday you know and he said
you're kidding and he said but look what
you do for a living and I said what he
said you wake the dead you making it for
him Lincoln and Jackie Robinson come
alive who do you think you're really
trying to wake up and from that moment
on I plowed towards finding away I've
never not been present on April 28th for
a long time it took me going to Ann
Arbor with my then small children and
renting a car and making a picnic out of
it and visiting a grave that we had
finally established my father had not
bothered to pick up the ashes and became
one of those forgotten repressed
memories of childhood and all the sudden
that this crisis we my brother and I
realized you know what we have to to do
this and so we track down our ashes at
some godforsaken Cemetery way outside of
him over and put a plaque there and for
many many years I would go there every
year with or without my daughters and
turn it into a an event and my mother's
name was Lila Li la an old
nineteenth-century spelling she was
named after her mother who was born in
the nineteenth century and when my
oldest daughter Sarah
had her first child she named her Lila
Li la what she was born on January 18th
2011 and I can't begin to tell you that
we never said Lila we still and even at
this talk at Telluride Film Festival we
refer to as mommy two men in their
sixties their mid-60s referring to mommy
because that's who she was right her
father went from daddy - dad our mother
always with mommy and I can't begin to
tell you that we never said the word
Lila
it was always draped in black crimp from
April 28 1965 until my granddaughter
Lila was born in which case we
so 20 times a day and we talked to her
and she is beautiful
and she you know the birds sing and so I
was doing and it's a wonderful wonderful
thing it has helped immeasurably with
what we were talking about before
anxiety and then the burden of that that
is that is really beautiful thank you so
much for sharing that and being so
forthcoming I think that not only is
your personal experience informative I
would imagine for a lot of people
listening as you mentioned I mean the
similarity of blowing out the candles
and wishing your mother to be back I'm
sure that transcends the experiences of
the two of you too many people who are
listening who have lost a loved one of
one type or another and I also think
it's really important and courageous of
you to talk very directly about your
father's struggles with with mental
illness with depression I have a very
severe bipolar depression on both sides
of my family and that applies to blood
relatives but also relatives by marriage
my aunt died of a percocet plus alcohol
overdose last year which was certainly
not correlated to depression and so the
this this this is really just a way of
saying thank you for talking so
vulnerably my my my late father-in-law
was an eminent psychologist and I felt
when he had given me this gift of saying
waking the dead that's what I did for a
living I realized that I was obligated
in some ways to to be transparent in my
in my individual biography and life if I
were going to continue doing what I was
doing
seemingly so successfully that is to say
if I was going to feel the ability to
talk about Abraham Lincoln
I needed also or Jackie Robinson I
needed the ability to talk about
Lila and Robert and about my brother
Rick and about my granddaughter Lila and
my daughter's Sara Lily Olivia and Willa
and do so with you know no
differentiation I'm sure they at times
would like to have a free and separate
life which they do have and because of
the notoriety of the film sometimes
there's people come up to me and talk to
me about things that are emotional you
know a veteran will say about the
Vietnam film this is the best thing I've
ever heard this helps me or I hear from
another veteran that his best friend
watched it and said he thinks he's okay
now I mean that's what happens and I
realized that the emotional archaeology
that I had said at the very beginning of
my first film I wish to pursue I was not
interested in merely excavating the
dried dates and facts and events in the
past but looking for an emotional
archaeology that would sort of glue
those shards those dry brittle shards
together and I have to by saying the
word emotional put an asterisk I do not
mean nostalgia or sentimentality that's
the enemy of good anything but I do
believe that there are higher emotions
that we are frightened of and so we
would retreat to a rational world most
of the time where one in one always
equals two when in fact what we want out
of our love of our sex perhaps out of
our face after out of our art out of
maybe just something simple like a cup
of tea or we're looking at a sunset we
want one and one to equal three and I'm
looking for that periodically that that
improbable equation to obtain in the
films that we are working on
well can I think that as a narrative
alchemist of sorts that you you have
managed with many of your films much of
your work
to create that that unlikely synergy of
one plus one equals three if you look at
all of the ingredients all of the
elements that you've pieced together
over decades the the this that the sum
is greater I'm gonna mess up this one I
always mess this one up what is the
whole is greater yeah so whole large
there we go but you know Jim that's
exactly it
when we see that let's just stop for a
second and take a rational approach
let's say the sum of the parts comes up
to here but the whole is up here what is
in there what is in there that's the
only question there is there's the
phenomenal world that we can see and and
we know is reflected light filled with
colors and sounds and all of these sorts
of things and there's a Numenor world an
unseen world which is actually much more
compelling if we knew how to trust and
access it and that's the big human
dilemma there's nobody gets out of this
alive no one gets out of this alive and
and this is a an amazing the depressing
sort of thing if you wish to take it
that way and we could be reasonably
excused as a sentient species for lying
in the fetal position sucking our thumb
waiting for that inevitable end but we
do not we raise babies and we tend
gardens and we build buildings and we
paint paintings and we make films and we
are in conversation with each other and
we're keeping as Witten ourselves
because if the wolf from the door the
wolf is the apprehension of our own
mortality and that's what story telling
you you know storytelling is basically
honey how was your day you know and then
you're required to edit human experience
and how you edit human experience is
really what it's all about you know
honey how your day you know it doesn't
begin I back slowly down the driveway
avoiding the garbage can at the
herb unless of course somebody t-bones
you and that's exactly the way you
describe it but you say how you'll never
believe what an sob my boss is and then
all of a sudden Arista Chilean poetics
that's not so scary Aristotle wrote an
essay called poetics about storytelling
beginning middle and end and protagonist
antagonist climax naina Moe hmm begin to
obey the laws of the editing of human
experience and by sharing the story like
raising a baby like tending a garden
like building a building we ensure a
kind of immortality well said and the
editing of the human experience is also
one of those ever so valuable
invisible arts read alongside music and
I want to remind people that your newest
work is country music explores the
history of uniquely American art form
country music and I have a long
description here that I'll include in
the show notes it'll also have already
been heard in the introduction I'm
holding it in my hand right here a story
of America one song at a time I cannot
wait to dig in and it premieres Sunday
September 15th 8 7 central you can also
stream it and it's available on the PBS
video app so you can find that on
pbs.org and also on the apps I'm very
excited about this and I'm so thrilled
that we were able to spend some time in
conversation today is there anything
else that you would like to say Ken
before before we wrap up I know I think
that I would let Merle Haggard who we
were very fortunate to be able to
interview for this country music saying
many many years ago six years ago and he
passed away soon afterwards he said it
it's what we believe in but can't see
like dreams and songs and souls and I
love that idea that songwriting creating
songs combining music might be these
things that we believe in
but can't see I've quoted you a couple
lines from Hank Williams you know could
you Johnny Cash at my door the leaves
are falling a cold wild wind will come
sweet hearts walk by together and I
still miss someone I don't know
that's all unseen and it is a common if
I sang it it would be a combination of
music and words and it's stuff that we
believe in like dreams and songs and
souls Merle Haggard one of the greatest
of all Emmylou Harris and our film later
on five episodes later this is in the
introduction that he says this the five
episodes later she said you want to know
what country music is get him Earl
Haggard record any Merle Haggard album
and put the needle just dating her put
the needle on any cut any [ __ ] it
doesn't matter which one and begin from
there so I think if if you take it from
this I always think when ever appears on
our film he's like you loose and I just
think if you take it from this this God
from Olympus that it's the things that
we believe in but can't see like dreams
and songs and soul you feel like you're
dealing with that new terminal world but
I was speaking about that you are
apprehending or trying to apprehend
something that is just beyond our Ken no
pun intended and is in there for us if
we expose ourselves to it and I think
that's the business of art that Leo
Tolstoy said art is the transfer of
emotion from one person to another
sounds pretty sounds pretty
straightforward and so on and I will
sort of leave you with two great
philosophers Merle Haggard and Leo
Tolstoy and it seems easy but sometimes
it's complicated and it's worth the
company it's worth the complication Ken
thank you so much for taking this time I
had I had just a wonderful
experience bouncing around here in the
ether having this conversation and I
highly recommend everybody check out
country music pbs.org forward slash
country music they can say hello
give a give a hand wave on the internet
at Ken Burns on Twitter and this has
been such a pleasure thank you Ken Ken
it's been my pleasure thank you so much
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week calm
I'll spell out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
peloton
I love peloton peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right to your home you
don't have to worry about fitting
classes into your schedule making it to
the studio or dealing with some commute
to the gym I have a peloton bike in my
master bedroom at home and it is one of
the first things that I do in the
morning I wake up meditate for 20
minutes and then I knock out a short 20
minute ride usually high-intensity
interval training or hit then I take
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's beautifully
convenient and has become something that
I actually looked forward to and I was
skeptical in the beginning I didn't
think I would dig it and I really do you
have a lot of options for one if you
like you can ride live with thousands of
other peloton riders from across the
country on the interactive leaderboards
motivated I tend to use a lot of the
classes on demand and have four to six
of them that I bookmark and use over and
over again there are up to fourteen new
classes every day with thousands of
classes on demand and there are a
variety of workouts to choose from 45
minute classes 20 minute burns hip hop
rock and roll low impact or high
intensity pick the class structure and
style their works for you
peloton has an amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
they really do have great instructors of
every possible personality and style and
that you can find one that you love no
matter what you're in the mood for
personally I use mat woofers a lot but I
use a bunch of them I'm promiscuous and
enjoy classes from Omaha to their
instructors with real time metrics you
can track the performance over time and
continue to beat your personal best I do
not think the gamification would work
for me and they really hit the nail on
the head it does work at least for me
tremendously well to keep me pushing
consistently so discover this
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings us to to experience to your home
peloton is offering listeners of this
podcast a limited time offer go to one
peloton comm that's spelled oh and the
PBL oto n calm enter the code
Tim podcast all onward at checkout and
get $100 off accessories with your
peloton bike purchase get a great
workout at home any time you want go to
one peloton calm and use the code Tim
podcast to get started this episode of
the Tim Farriss shows brought to you by
athletic greens I get us all the time if
I could only take one supplement what
would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
and I use it in a lot of different ways
I travel with it to avoid getting sick
or the helped mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure out full of performance and
overall it covers my bases if I can't
get what I need from whole food meals
through
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of these one
dose bags in other words if you buy
athletic greens as a first-time buyer
you now get for a limited time and extra
$79 in free product so check out the
details at athletic greens comm forward
slash Tim again that's athletic greens
dot-com forward slash Tim for your free
travel pack with any purchase
[Applause]
you
you
you